foreign
object crashed into the Kremlin in early
May
a few weeks later several residential
buildings were hit in Moscow
while Russia's strikes are almost a
daily reality for the Ukrainian Capital
Kiev
these are the first drone assaults on
Russia's capital since the war in
Ukraine began the population in big
cities like Moscow and Saint Petersburg
have been somewhat insulated from this
war and now it's basically come to their
doorstep The Wall Street Journal
analyzed social media clips of the
attacks and spoke with joint experts to
understand what happened
and what it means for Russia's
involvement in the war
this video on May 3rd appears to show
one of two drones seconds before it was
shot down over the Kremlin according to
the Russian government
an aviation analyst with defense
intelligence firm James said it could
have been a small drone up to 10 feet
across most likely launched from Russian
territory other Aviation Experts of
journals spoke with suggested the
aircraft had a larger wingspan with a
possible flying range in the hundreds of
miles enough to cover the distance
between Moscow and Ukrainian territory
several drones could fit that
description including the Ukrainian uj22
and the chinese-made Mugen 5 used by
both sides
on May 30th a drawing crashed outside
the Russian capital and several more
drones struck at least three residential
buildings in Moscow one verified social
media video captured the drawing with
their peculiar airframe design experts
Sayers seem to have a push mechanism
with the propeller in the back
this train is visually consistent with a
type of Kamikaze drone recently reported
on in Ukraine according to news agencies
Story full
known as Beaver it is a self-initiated
drone project by a Ukrainian blogger
however some experts notes that the
shape of the new drone is slightly
different from the One filmed outside
the Russian capital
military experts say it's impossible to
tell from the footage who launched the
attacks whether it was the Ukrainian
military or a pro-ukrainian group
working inside Russia in both cases
Russia blamed
kievable
and Ukraine denied the allegations
one American drawing expert said the use
of drones which can fly hundreds of
miles could also indicate military
involvement in the construction and
development of those drawings
the attacks on Moscow have raised
questions about Russia's air defense
abilities
[Music]
some military experts say the attacks
demonstrate that Russian airspace is not
secure and that it's possible to evade
some of its air defenses
they added that unlike other more
damaging attacks that targeted military
bases and oil Depots on Russian
territory the drone strikes on Moscow
were largely psychological and symbolic
there'll certainly be an impact on the
Russian psyche because very much in
these big cities people have felt that
they are untouched almost by this Warner
the government has used these attacks
basically to say see this is why we are
taking action in Ukraine but this has
been somewhat of a wake-up call for the
population there are recent polls that
show that one of the main topics that
Russians think about today is the war
that is very different to say nine
months ago when in the big cities in
particular in Moscow people were very
much going about their daily lives
one military expert said the Kremlin is
trying to downplay the impacts of the
attacks on the capital but if they
continue the question is whether the
Kremlin will manage to convince the
population to accept this as a new Norm